by the way free YSL free Gunner I want
to know because I know that you guys
never had a real beef I think it was
more internet comedy Fred [ __ ] but like
how crazy bro I remember when that song
came out every Club you walked into you
had to play that [ __ ] record oh I'm
still bumped that [ __ ] yeah my kids like
that [ __ ] my kids be in the backseat I
can't [ __ ] with Freddie yes I'd be like
you little [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying but uh like hey man you know
um
I don't have nothing against uh none of
them I don't even really know I mean you
you and you and Doug have a gold record
together definitely Old English
definitely I mean that's that's a big
deal yeah it's a totally big deal like
um
you know then I you know I know some
people on their side when they Camp I
know Ebony shout out to ebony
um I don't have no you know Coral with
uh you know with Ghana yeah I knew you I
mean you told I mean obviously I knew
behind the scenes you had never was
never nothing you know internet jokes is
internet jokes you know I mean you make
a lot of Internet Crime Stoppers joke
was you know the Crime Stoppers joke I
mean T.I did that too you know what I'm
saying and when we joked about that and
when I did that T.I called me and we had
a conversation and I don't have no bad
words for TI either you know what I'm
saying like I said it was just to me it
was just jokes you know what I'm saying
um but you also have to understand
sometimes you're you're a rapper so when
you joke about other rappers it comes
off like more differently than if like
you know but I ain't trying to use I
ain't trying to sell records that they
they expense or anything and uh none of
that nature you know what I mean I don't
even really care about you know um you
know uh you know selling as much as them
or being on a level musically I got a
you know core that I satisfy and and
it's down the third so like what Gunner
was like saying oh man when I ditched
Freddie Gibbs this is going to be the
biggest moment of his career I was
really expecting some bars I was like oh
[ __ ] like this thing about to rip me
apart you know what I'm saying so I was
waiting on it you know shout out to
Gunner I don't I'm not sure like we're
really going to Gunner for the bars I
mean I was expecting something I was
expected to you know you know but it was
but what we got was a funny song and you
know it was fun it was a fun moment so
shout out to him for that and you know I
hope they get through that legal
situations